plaisir sort par la petite porte de ces
playoffs de fédérale 3 après avoir perdu
le premier match sur le terrain
d'anthony le dimanche 1er mai 11 10 le
plaisir ont été éliminés sur leur
terrain ce week end les yvelinois se
sont inclinés 22 à 17 au terme d'un
match à suspense devant plus de 600
spectateurs
ils ont pas volé leur victoire
félicitations ils l'ont pas volée
certainement à mieux maîtriser le jeu au
pied que nous en première mi-temps avec
le vent on l'a mal mal
c'est mal servis vivent mal utiliser le
vent il vaut mieux utiliser des canots
et après on savait que c'était de deux
équipes qui étaient proches l'une de
l'autre pour match aller on a fait pas
mal d'erreurs
je pense qu'il ya des moments clés du
match monde marqué ou marquent en effet
10 heures
individuels collectifs de soi tactique
anthony c'est une belle équipe ils ont
réussi à exploiter tout ça
je pense que sur les deux matches tous
deux montés grand avec cette défaite
plaisir est définitivement éliminé de la
course à la montée l'objectif fixé en
début de saison
des changements sont donc attendus cet
été pour renforcer l'équipe
s'il faut servir de cette saison pour
l'an prochain pour rebondir et voilà les
chercher cette montée il faudra voir à
l'intersaison risque à marcher sk pas
marcher voire peut-être un petit peu
recrutement voir un petit peu ce que la
production des joueurs comme toutes les
saisons repartir pour retravailler pour
une saison et essayer d'arriver à se
demander si l'équipe première s'arrête
dès ce premier tour de playoffs la
réserve continue son chemin les plaisirs
oies se sont imposés ce dimanche contre
anthony 13 à 9